how's it going everyone I got some game
news for you so if you're a gamer like
me you may or may not have seen the
trailer for the videogame PlayStation
all-stars battle royale if you don't
know what that is let me explain it's
pretty much Super Smash Brothers with
Sony characters and this game has been
getting a lot of heat why because it's
Super Smash Brothers with Sony
characters not even lying you look at
the gameplay you're like yeah that Smash
Brothers so this isn't the first game to
do that you remember that Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles mashup game yeah totally
copied Smash Brothers they're - he's
just Smash Brothers with Ninja Turtles
right I like a good original game myself
when someone can nail an original game
I'm like awesome barring a couple of
exceptions they're hard to come by
nowadays
yes PlayStation all-stars battle royale
is ripping off Super Smash Brothers in
the same way that 90% of side scroller
platformers have ripped off super mario
brothers or rock band ripped off Guitar
Hero and then Guitar Hero ripped off
rock bands funny how that works or Call
of Duty ripped off battlefield which
ripped off Medal of Honor and yes 90% of
fighting games have ripped off Street
Fighter II see you see how this argument
works a lot of games have ripped off a
lot of other games so the question at
that point is is that a bad thing I mean
really after you played Super Smash
Brothers for the first time didn't you
sit down and just be like dude that
would be awesome if other companies did
this like if Sony did this which now
they are well Microsoft did this and
they can have Master Chief and Marcus
Fenix and
give them fears for nothing else at the
end of that game you can fight the red
ring of death and try to take it out I'm
not expecting PlayStation all-stars to
be better than smash brothers I think
smash brothers is the formula that
people are going off of and nothing
beats the original formula got like when
Mario 64 came out it was the best 3d
platformer that was out every other
company tried to do a 3d platformer but
it wasn't as good as Mario 64 again
games borrowing from other game it's not
the first time someone was like oh yeah
Nintendo nailed it let's do that thing
is there were a number of third-person
3d platformer games that were good so I
don't knock them for using the same
system that Nintendo did I mean if you
want to get a bunch of different
characters together from a bunch of
different games and a bunch of different
genres and have them just fighting an
all-out brawl the smash brothers setup
is pretty much the best way to go about
it so you almost can't blame another
company for being like we want to do
this but that's the perfect system if we
use that setup or copying them if we
don't use that setup it's not as good
what to do Sony has a cool roster of
characters they're gonna have
third-party characters in this game also
you get to play them all in a Smash
Brothers setting and that's just not bad
it's just not bad to me I think that's
cool any world where I can beat the
living [ __ ] out of Kratos with parappa
the rapper it's not a bad world to live
in so there you go I'm gonna get it when
it comes out if you have a Playstation 3
and you've played PlayStation games for
the past 20 years or so odds are you're
probably gonna want to get this game
because you've wanted to see these
certain characters fight for my money as
long as they have Cain and Raphael from
the legacy of kain games dude I'm golden
I'll get the special edition at that
point so those playstation allstars copy
and Smash Brothers yes does it look cool
absolutely but we only have one trailer
out right now no one to play I haven't
played it hopefully I'll get to play
that packs this year or something
totally is just all speculation I don't
know how the game play is here you guys
Sony if you're watching I'll give you a
little advice if you're going for the
Smash Brothers Brawl vibe just don't
have the characters randomly trip when
they're fighting like they do in Smash
Brothers Brawl keep that out and
everything will be fine
that was dumb so have you seen the
trailer PlayStation all-stars battle
royale what do you think you think it's
ripping off Smash Brothers too much
undeniably it is copying Smash Brothers
I'm just wondering how much is too much
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more